(crowd cheering)
- All right, as always,
let's finish up with one last story
we hope will brighten your day.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(cheers and applause)
At 28, our next guest is already
a successful entrepreneur,
whose product is sold
at major retailers, including Target.
She's created a line of dolls,
that not only reflect
a range of skin colors,
eye shapes, and face shapes,
they have natural hair for kids to style.
It's called Healthy Roots,
and we have the Mastermind behind them
on the line right, now
watching on NBC 10 WJAR.
What's up, Yelitsa?
How you doing?
(cheers and applause)
- I'm good. How are you?
- So, I have to say,
this all started as a
school project, right?
- Yeah. So, while I was
studying illustration
at the Rhode Island School of Design,
I was tasked with
redesigning a fairytale character.
I ultimately chose Rapunzel and turned her
into a little brown girl
with kinky, curly hair,
so that I could show
other little brown girls
we can be princesses, too.
From there, my classmates were telling me,
"Wow, this looks like a doll."
And, I hadn't really
thought of it that way,
but then I went on Facebook and talked
to my friends and realized,
"Wow, we didn't really have dolls
that looked like us growing up."
And, I saw an opportunity to do more
than just paint a doll brown,
but create an educational
hair play experience
for little Black girls, so that they know
that their natural hair is gorgeous.
So, from class project to
$50,000 in crowdfunding,
and then raising $1.2 million,
we now have a product line that represents
the diversity that I
didn't have growing up,
and shows it on toy shelves
at stores like Target.
- That's incredible that this
came out of an assignment.
So, they're not just dolls,
like, this is something that
kids can interact with, right?
That's the important
thing, as well, right?
- Exactly. It's-- hair is so important.
I think people was like, "It's just hair."
It's like, "No, it's an
experience for people."
I never had products like this growing up,
and not being able to do my hair
until I was 20 years old is crazy.
So, why not design something
that helps little girls
learn to love their hair
just the way that it is?
So, here's a doll that
with hair you can wash and style,
learn how to use shampoo, conditioner,
box braids, Bantu knots,
all the beautiful things that
our natural hair can do
that we should celebrate.
This is what this doll
is designed to show them.
- I love it.
Thank you so much, Yelitsa.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(ding)
Oh, my gosh.
The dolls are so cute.
All right, so we've hit
the time when we usually
give our guest a thousand dollars
courtesy of our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
But, since Yelitsa, well,
she's doing all right.
She's got food in her pan.
She's doing all right.
We're gonna give it to
someone in the audience.
So, look under your seat.
(audience cheers)
Look under your seats,
and there's a check that's
taped under your seat.
(drum roll)
Where is it? Where is it?
(excited music)
Yes!
(crowd cheering)
Hello! Stand up.
What's your name?
- Suzanne Fernando.
- Did you say Suzanne?
- Yes.
- Suzanne, what are you gonna do
with that thousand dollahs?
- Wow. Maybe go on another vacation.
(laughs)
- Oh, my God.
Thank you for not
saying, "Just pay bills."
That's awesome.
- Thank you!
- That's so awesome.
Have so much fun.
- Thank you so much.
- Okay. Thank you to all our guests today
Catherine Zeta-Jones, Matt
Iseman, Lisette Olivera,
Danielle Kartes, and Lawrence Zarian.
Y'all have a great day, and if it's not,
well, try and change it.